thank you
I need a cap
able
thank you
we talk later
I think we just take the first two okay
foreign
the chair recognizes the member from
Farmington representative Petrie who
moves the house adjourned from the
session January 4th 2023. are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
aye those opposed nay the eyes have it
and houses adjourned
the house will attend a request for
leaves of absence
day illness Representatives Hamlet
Richard Rambo the day important business
Representatives a bear action Alexander
Balboni bolio Bickford Bixby Bill Boyd
brewyard Carol Brown Richard Brown Tom
Cahill Cannon cascaden Coker Connor
Cornell Darby Delorenzo di Silvestro
datsy Allison Emerick Faulkner fellows
foot gagne Gibbs Gilman gold Greece and
grota harb Haskins Heath Hill Hobson
James Horgan
Heath Howard Hines genesian Judy Jones
Juris Kennedy Catherine Kenny Seth King
NAB kofault kutab Lane Lanza Leon
Leclerc lewicki John McDonald Mackenzie
Manion Mason Missouri
McCarter McConkey Carol McGuire McLean
Mooney Morris Muirhead muns Nagel Ray
Newman Sue Newman Newton Noble Nutter
Upham Zachary nutting Parr partial power
payer Peterson pedernal petrigno
Phillips Finney cuartielo Reynolds Karen
Reed renzullo Shapiro Schmidt South
seaworth Siebert ceiling sellers
shirtless smart spear Sinclair Staub
Stone Sullivan scitec tillez
treeleven trottier true Tudor Alan
turcott verville Thomas Walsh Weber
weary Woodcock the day illness in the
family representative Anita Burroughs
the day death in the family represented
plosage
disease of absence will be shall be
granted unless otherwise ordered by the
house the house for 1030 introduction of
guests
guests of Representative Sweeney Charles
post husband of Representative post
Susan amen wife of Representative Eamonn
Heather Pearl wife of Senator Pearl
guest of the speaker they are with us in
the gallery today
Welcome to the New Hampshire house
[Applause]
the house will attend to a resolution
Mr Speaker Representatives
Weiler and miler
offer the following resolved at the
House of Representatives notify the
honorable Senate that it is ready to
meet in joint convention for the
purposes of hearing the report of The
Joint Committee appointed to compare and
count the votes for governor and
executive Council and for the
inauguration of the governor and for the
taking of Oath by the executive Council
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye those opposed nay the
eyes have it the resolution is adopted
you need John
right
hours
thank you
the house will come to order
the house will attend to a senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate is now
ready to meet with the House of
Representatives and Joint convention for
the purpose of hearing the report of The
Joint Committee appointed to compare and
count the votes for governor and Council
for the inauguration of Governor The
Honorable Christopher T sununu and The
Taking of The Oath by the executive
Council
chair recognizes the Sergeant at Arms
the honorables
[Applause]
foreign
Mr Speaker president of the Senate The
Honorable Jeb Bradley of Wolfeboro
[Applause]
The Joint convention will come to water
The Joint convention will be attentive
to a report from The Joint Committee on
votes counts for the governor and
executive Council
speaker representative Stephen Smith
Sanborn and Wilhelm and Senators Carson
and Susie offer the following report The
Joint Committee appointed to compare and
count the votes for the governor and
executive Council reports that it has
attended to its duties and the vote is
correct
we now have the introduction and seating
of special guests
please remain seated until all the
guests are introduced and in their seats
Jay recognizes the house Clerk
Mr Speaker family and guests of the
executive Council
Mr Speaker family and guests of Governor
Christopher T sununu
thank you
great
Mr Speaker
Commissioners and department heads for
the State of New Hampshire
performance
Mr Speaker representing law enforcement
Colonel Nathan Noyes of the New
Hampshire State Police and the Attorney
General John fermilla
foreign
Mr Speaker administrative judge of the
New Hampshire circuit courts The
Honorable David D King
Mr Speaker the Chief Justice of the New
Hampshire Superior Courts The Honorable
Tina Neto
Mr Speaker associate Justice of the New
Hampshire Supreme Court The Honorable
Patrick e Donovan
Mr Speaker associate Justice of the New
Hampshire Supreme Court The Honorable
Anna Barbara Hans Marconi
Mr Speaker the Chief Justice of the New
Hampshire Supreme Court The Honorable
Gordon J MacDonald
[Applause]
Mr Speaker the leadership of the New
Hampshire House of Representatives
world leadership
Mr Speaker former Speaker of the House
The Honorable Douglas W skin scam and
Junior and The Honorable Stella scammon
foreign
[Applause]
Mr Speaker the former executive
counselor for uh District number three
The Honorable Ruth Griffin and son
Michael Griffin
[Applause]
foreign
Mr Speaker former executive counselor
for district number three The Honorable
Russell Prescott
[Applause]
Mr Speaker former New Hampshire
Congressman The Honorable Charles F bass
and Son Jonathan Bass
foreign
speaker former United States Senator The
Honorable John E sununu and kitty sununu
[Applause]
[Music]
Mr Speaker former United States Senator
The Honorable Kelly ayotte
[Applause]
Mr Speaker former Governor The Honorable
John H sununu
[Applause]
Mr Speaker the New Hampshire State
Treasurer The Honorable Monica mezapelli
thank you
Mr Speaker the New Hampshire Secretary
of State The Honorable David M Scanlon
Mr Speaker the Reverend clergy Pastor
Michael Worsley
foreign
we're going to be in a brief recess for
about 10 minutes
oh I don't know I don't think so
oh
the chair recognizes the house Clark Mr
Speaker executive counselor representing
district one The Honorable Joseph T
Kenny
[Applause]
[Music]
Mr Speaker executive counselor
representing District Number Two The
Honorable Cindy warmington
[Applause]
[Music]
Mr Speaker executive Council
representing District 3 The Honorable
Janet Stevens
[Applause]
Mr Speaker executive counselor
representing District 4 The Honorable
Theodore gazis
foreign
[Applause]
Mr Speaker executive Council
representing District Five The Honorable
David K wheeler
[Applause]
okay Mr Speaker escorted by Major
General David michelitis adjutant
general of the State of New Hampshire
his Excellency Governor Christopher T
sununu Valerie sununu and their children
thank you
[Applause]
you're all standing The Joint convention
will please stand and be revenantly
attended while the invocation is offered
by Pastor Michael Worsley of Manchester
foreign
good afternoon everyone
first of all I'd like to give honor to
God who is the father of my Lord and
Savior Jesus Christ
honor to Governors the new my friend my
brother
honor to First Lady Valerie
and giving honor to all of you elected
officials I am both humbled and honored
to be here and to open uh today with
prayer
I take prayer very seriously
I don't take what I'm about to do
lightly at all
as I go into prayer it is important that
when we pray we pray with understanding
so I want to share with you as I open in
prayer why I am why I'm praying and what
I am praying for
as the minister of the Gospel I want you
to understand
what you should expect as elected
officials from a true Christian
or someone that says they are minister
of the Gospel
what you shouldn't expect is him to
rally against you as our elected
official and governor
you shouldn't expect him to blast you on
Facebook
impose signs about you that's not what a
Christian in the minister of the Gospel
is not to do
but here Paul
made very clear instructions to his
young he called child in the faith this
pastor Timothy
and before I pray here's where I want
you to understand what I am praying
Paul says here first of all then
I urge that in treaties and prayers
petitions and Thanksgiving
be made on behalf of all men
now in the Hebrew in Greek all means all
for kings and all who are in Authority
so that we may lead a tranquil and quiet
life
this is good and acceptable in the sight
of God our savior who desires all men to
be saved and to come to the knowledge of
the truth
for there is one God and one mediator
also between God and Men the man Christ
Jesus
as I go into prayer today when I
consider where we are right now in our
nation
as I pray for you as our elected
officials and Authority
I want you to keep this in mind
I don't care where you sit on the aisle
what your policies may be but as a
minister of the Gospel
it is our duty according to scripture to
pray for you and that's what I would do
by your heads father in The Mighty and
matchless name of Jesus
Lord I come before your throne of Mercy
fathers I'm gathered here with those who
are in Authority here in this great
state
father beginning with our governor Lord
I lift him up right now before you
praying oh God that he continues as he
leads this state
seeking Godly wisdom
father I pray a hedge of protection
around him around his family father Lord
as they bear with him Lord in the mighty
name of Jesus father I pray for every
elected official in the earshot of my
voice
father I pray that as they come together
and make the decisions in the direction
that this state goes Lord I pray
protection for them as well
Lord I lift up all of law enforcement
here in the state of New Hampshire
father I pray that collectively father
God there would be this Unity father as
our elected officials will move forward
in 2023.
that Lord with Direction
father with wisdom
as they make the decisions for this
state Lord I pray that father all would
be done to your honor and to your glory
in Jesus name amen
the members of The Joint convention will
please remain standing for the posting
of Colors by the New Hampshire National
Guard honor guard
will you join me in the Pledge of
Allegiance
Charlotte with Charlotte cardi New
Hampshire's 2022 kid Governor from
Plaistow who will now lead us in the
Pledge of Allegiance
the United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
please remain standing while Molly
Dennehy of Concord sings our national
anthem
oh oh say can you see
by the dawn's early light what's so
proudly we
held at the
twilight's last gleaming
whose broad stripes and bright stars
through the
perilous fight or the ramparts we've
watched were so
gallantly streaming
and the rockets regular
the bombs bursting in air
gave proof through the night that our
flag was still there
oh
say does that
Star-Spangled
Banner yet when
live or the land of the free
and the home of the brave
[Applause]
The Honorable Judd Gordon J McDonnell
Chief Justice of the New Hampshire
Supreme Court will now administer the
oath of office to governor sununu
good morning
please raise your right hand and wear
appropriate state your name and town of
residence
I I Chris Christopher T sununu of
Newfield New Hampshire do solemnly swear
do solemnly swear that I will bear faith
and true allegiance that I will bear
faith and true allegiance to the United
States of America through the United
States of America and the state of New
Hampshire and the state of New Hampshire
and will support the Constitutions
thereof and will support the
Constitutions thereof so help me God so
help me God I I Christopher sununu do
solemnly and sincerely do solemnly and
sincerely swear and affirm swear and
affirm that I will faithfully and
impartially that I will faithfully and
impartially discharge and perform
discharge and perform all the duties
incumbent on me all the duties incumbent
on me as Governor as Governor according
to the best of my abilities according to
the best of my abilities agreeable to
the rules and regulations of this
constitution agreeable to the rules and
regulations of this
and the laws of the State of New
Hampshire and the laws of the State of
New Hampshire so help me guys so help me
God congratulations
thank you
congratulations
[Music]
Governor sooner will now administer the
author of office to The Honorable
executive counselors
thank you very much Mr Speaker
I'm just going to note right off I think
the gavel is getting bigger
not that he ever needs it were the
honorable executive Council please rise
please raise your right hand
[Music]
I state your name
of
do solemnly swear
that I will bear faith in true
Allegiance
to the United States of America
and the state of New Hampshire
and will support the Constitutions
thereof
so help me God
I state your name
do solemnly and sincerely
swear in affirm
that I will faithfully and impartially
discharge and perform
all the duties incumbent upon me
as an executive counselor
according to the best of my abilities
agreeably to the rules and regulations
of this constitution
and the laws of the State of New
Hampshire
so help me God
congratulations
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
congratulations counselors
The Joint convention will be attentive
to the inaugural address by Christopher
T sanunu
thank you again Mr Speaker
I'm going to
hey David
I have to get my hellos in good morning
well good afternoon I guess we're past
noon
Mr Speaker
Mr Senate President Jim Bradley
you look good there you look good Jim
honorable members of the house and the
Senate uh to Chief Justice McDonald and
The Honorable members of our Judiciary
that are joining us today to members of
the executive Council that are here with
us that we have now sworn in
congratulations to the members of our
commissioners all the Commissioners and
and the agency heads that are joining us
today and obviously to our fellow
Granite Staters who are watching at home
welcome Happy New Year it is great to to
really be back and I can say that with a
lot of confidence
um also joining us before we get started
I did invite a few individuals uh today
that really I think represent a big part
of what I want to touch upon and what we
want to talk about a big part of our
foundation of our process I think of
what makes New Hampshire really special
really stand out from the crowd that's
Civics right our process our very unique
process of of state government and how
we do things here in New Hampshire it
really is the foundation of our success
and frankly the Envy uh of the of the
rest of the country so today there's a
few special guests I want to introduce
today we have Martha Madsen who is the
executive director of New Hampshire
Civics is joining us
um as Martha I'm looking for martha
where hey how are you good to see you
Martha um that's wonderful a wonderful
organization that promotes Civics all
across the state and Martha uh came here
with our New Hampshire kid Governor
Charlotte
Charlie awesome great job
Charlotte cotty uh sixth grade now right
sixth grade in the fifth grade she
became New Hampshire's kid Governor
you're still holding the title at least
I think for a little bit longer until we
bring in a new kid Governor this year an
amazingly uh powerful uh program and
opportunity for a lot of the kids across
the state along with us we also have Mrs
Mallory lankau this is lank how are you
up there with the students from growth
in high school good to see you guys
the Civics and government classes come
down from Groveton to join us today
that's wonderful good to see everybody
up there
um obviously want to acknowledge a few
folks
um without whom it's not possible uh
where's Mike where is he where's my dad
so there's my parents obviously my kids
my family and the one person who has
just given everything Valerie
oh
I always get choked up when we talk
about Valerie I always get choked up
so for the first time a lot I think a
lot of people have to remind folks for
the first time in four years even though
we get elected every two uh I do stand
before you here in Representatives Hall
uh to deliver the inaugural address the
last time I I did it we did it in a TV
studio I don't know if anybody watched
Frank it was a really good speech by the
way I don't know if anybody saw it but
it's actually a really great great
speech if I do say so myself but we are
finally here we're back we're in person
uh we're shoulder to shoulder and what
an amazing opportunity that is
so today I have the honor of delivering
my fourth inaugural address and an
interesting fun fact I was told this
this morning it is the first time in
American history a little Civics fun
fact for you that a four-term governor
is being sworn in by a fourth Supreme
Court Justice
so you're famous now uh chief justice
McDonald
um which is even more amazing
considering we get elected every two
years but we've had four justices so
there's your fun Civics fact for the day
it really does continue to be the honor
of a lifetime to serve as the governor
of the Granite State it's a great state
and I think of standing here uh just six
short years ago
it really seems like a lifetime right I
mean given what we've all gone through
given the amazing things and the
accomplishments that we've been able to
achieve both within the legislative body
working within the executive branch but
we always have to appreciate that our
work really isn't done families and
small business businesses are truly
counting on us to keep delivering
results
over the last six years New Hampshire
really has become an island of Freedom
surrounded by frankly highly taxed and
highly regulated States we're a harbor
for Citizens that are fleeing or leaving
their home state to in really pursuit of
that Live Free or Die way of life
we continue to open up doors of
opportunity giving families the freedom
to choose their path that best suits
their needs
we've provided leadership that pivots
the individual ahead of the system
sounds obvious to us here in New
Hampshire but it's actually quite unique
it ensures that everyone regardless of
race or gender or income religion
whatever it might be everyone has the
same opportunities to succeed
when other states were slow rolling the
vaccine just the vaccine distribution we
went fast we gave everyone that freedom
to choose when other states shut down
schools we open them up when other
states close down their businesses we
kept the lights on and we invested in
their success when other states use the
pandemic as an excuse to raise taxes or
permanently alter government
government's influence it was New
Hampshire that cut taxes it was New
Hampshire that said no to mandates and
it was New Hampshire that became the
fastest growing state in the region
foreign
politics out the window at the time
there's a lot of political Rancor across
this country but we in New Hampshire
through those politics out the window we
followed data we chartered a new course
and as a result not only is our our
economy the strongest in the region but
we were ranked as one of the safest
states in the country during the covet
crisis and simply put New Hampshire is
the Envy of the nation it is the gold
standards of the states and it is the
number one place to live work and raise
a family
foreign
New Hampshire we are recognizing look
I'm going to bring I'm gonna brag I'm
just going to tell you we have some
amazing statistics to back up the
successes the successes that we've had
today New Hampshire we're recognized as
having America's best return on taxpayer
investment ranked as the number one
state for personal freedoms the number
one state for Economic Opportunity the
number one state for Public Safety the
number one state when we look at the
lowest poverty rate in America
foreign
now look these these rankings are
wonderful they are nice and all but they
do not tell the full story right that
story of the New Hampshire Advantage
what it is
and I I admit I'll be the first one to
tell you it ain't a fair fight right
when you're comparing New Hampshire to
49 other states it's not a fair fight
they get jealous my phone will start
ringing from other Governors I get it
um but we do have something to be very
proud of and it didn't come by accident
it came with hard work all the way down
from the governor to the 1.4 million of
the citizens that create that
opportunity we are to live for your die
State and we don't need those rankings
to just validate our success story for
over 200 years every other state has
effectively been playing catch-up so
instead of the rankings let's look at
some of the real facts together over the
past six years we've crafted three
balanced budgets with no new taxes and
we're going to do it again
we delivered full day kindergarten
we delivered full day kindergarten we
delivered a historic school choice bill
that puts students over systems
and we did this all while spending more
money on public school students than
ever before
we built a whole new treatment and
recovery system and it's getting results
and when 48 other states unfortunately
we saw what was happening nationally we
saw their overdose deaths they were
skyrocketing during the pandemic but New
Hampshire bucked that National Trend
showing that our doorway system truly
worked
and after years of talk we finally
delivered a paid family medical leave
that's voluntary that's affordable and
that does not include an income tax
[Applause]
we made historic investments into new
housing we capitalized on new ideas like
the One-Stop veterans campus in Franklin
to support our nation's Heroes it's the
first of its kind in the nation
and over the last six years we
downshifted cash not costs to our cities
and towns returning hundreds of millions
of dollars and tax relief for our
citizens and in fact since I became
Governor 82 percent of the cities and
towns in the state have seen their
property tax rate go down
now none of it's an accident it's the
result of smart management responsible
decision making and simply putting
individuals simply putting people first
so it was unbelievably good is this past
six years have been and despite our
record of success we do have tough
challenges ahead and the most pressing
one that affects every family and
business across the state is this
looming energy crisis
Summers without air conditioning in New
Hampshire they can be tough but Winters
without heat in New Hampshire they can
be deadly
when it comes to solutions to the energy
crisis we must have the courage to take
politics out of the equation and
together together last fall was an
amazing opportunity we passed the most
comprehensive energy relief package the
state had ever seen Republicans and
Democrats came together to make a real
impact for families struggling with high
electric bills making available 35
million dollars in electricity and
heating credits for more New Hampshire
families increasing and also increasing
investments into our existing
electricity and fuel assistance programs
thank you guys
[Applause]
and with everything comes balance which
is why in addition to these new
Investments we continue to explore
longer term options longer term options
such as offshore wind or more hydropower
out of Canada expanding renewable solar
projects especially for lower income
families and municipalities but there's
more that needs to be done and our Focus
must remain on reducing that cost burden
on citizens rather than adding to it
electric grade payers are already
getting crushed by this National energy
crisis we see it every day therefore we
have to reject that legislation that
will impose additional unnecessary costs
I vetoed legislation that would have
imposed millions in new costs on
citizens in the time of Crisis and
frankly I was very excited to be the
first to stand up and stop that crazy 17
Cent Regional gas tax increase that
Massachusetts wanted to throw down on us
my veto pen has plenty of ink and will
always be ready for to protect our
citizens from that kind of nonsense
[Applause]
when it comes to energy policy we can't
just follow States like Massachusetts
and New York and California just the
opposite we have to continue to protect
our interests from the policies of other
states and ensure that we have the
resources needed to make our voice heard
it's critical that we come together and
get this done everyone from Seniors to
those on fixed incomes young families
they're all counting on us to get this
right
now I'm going to change gears just a
little bit
uh the last time I stood up here in
Representatives Hall addressing you I
started by thanking then Secretary of
State Bill Gardner uh and at the time it
was then Deputy deputy secretary of
state Dave Scanlon where's Dave
hey Mr secretary how are you today
at that time we wanted to take the
opportunity we had just come off of the
2020 election and we took the
opportunity to thank the countless poll
workers the town moderators the all
those Town officials across the state on
a job well done on a successful and
seamless 2020 first in the nation
presidential primary we all remember
quite well after the 2020 debacle in
Iowa sorry Iowa but you screwed up
sure Governor Reynolds will give me a
call the nation really did if you
remember they turned their eyes towards
New Hampshire right
the world descended onto
we're going to follow us here the stakes
were very high but it was nothing that
New Hampshire could not handle and at a
time of electoral uncertainty and doubt
in our elections New Hampshire we put on
a clinic for the rest of the nation in
terms of how to administer elections and
America breathed a huge sigh of relief
as we we restored confidence to the
entire system
and this is an issue that we across
party lines truly stand in unison on
today the New Hampshire State Democrat
Party the New Hampshire State Republican
party the democrat-led federal
delegation the Republican Governor the
house the Senate everyone across the
board is standing together pushing back
on this attempt that we hear to erode
such an important process it's a strong
message of bipartisanship and frankly as
strong as anyone you've ever seen here
in the state because we all know that
recently you have the power Brokers and
the Washington driven Democrat Party
they've made it clear that they believe
New Hampshire's time is up when it comes
to the first in the nation primary
Washington Democrats are so misinformed
they chose South Carolina to take our
place in 2020 South Carolina their their
primary had a voter turnout of about 16
percent while New Hampshire was setting
records in 2020 the last time an
incumbent president was on the ballot in
South Carolina they canceled their
primary depriving voters of a choice
ensuring that the power Brokers within
that state just chose who to war award
their delegates to that's not the
Democracy it's incumbent protection and
something that New Hampshire will never
engage in
foreign
message for President Biden you can come
and try and take it but it is never
going to happen it is just not in our
DNA to give it up
and take orders from Washington D.C
and you've heard it all out there we're
not going to be blackmailed we're not
going to be threatened and we will not
give up
the New Hampshire primary has stood the
test of time it gives everyone a fair
shot no matter what your name ID no
matter how much money you have in your
campaign account or the elected office
you held before running for president
for 100 years New Hampshire has given
voice to lesser-known candidates and
provided a pathway to the presidency for
anyone dedicated enough to test their
medal with the New Hampshire voters so
mark my words
come next year secretary of state state
Scanlon will ensure that the New
Hampshire does Remain the first in the
nation presidential primary thank you
sir
foreign
[Applause]
primary is something that everyone
across New Hampshire and across the
aisle can agree on but we know there are
other hot button issues where there are
clear ideological differences between us
of course we can have our disagreements
but it is incumbent upon all of us to
not let those disagreements get in the
way of individual opportunity we
negotiate we work together we give a
little to get a lot because that's the
accountability that the New Hampshire
voters demand and frankly deserve of
their public servants
New Hampshire like America is not immune
to political extremism but we must do
everything we can in our power to push
back against it
the voters this past November sent a
very clear message they want leaders who
can deliver
you don't just kick the can down the
road or blame the next person in line
you face challenges head on you invite
solution driven individuals to the table
to work the problem and what a lot of
people don't appreciate is that's the
fun part right the redesign and the
repurpose of our systems is really what
keeps New Hampshire on top the voters of
our great state elected a near evenly
divided legislature presenting an
awesome opportunity for this type of
cooperation
and we have a speaker
[Music]
[Applause]
but what a great lesson what a great
civics lesson and challenge that we do
find ourselves in
the last time the New Hampshire
legislature was this narrowly divided
was 1871 and um as a side note I think
the Josiah Bartlett Center did a really
amazing piece on what happened in 1871.
if you think the political Rancor of
today is bad you should read that
article it is absolutely crazy it makes
what's going on today like look like a
softball game it was really crazy what
happened back then
but
to make sure
that we don't let some of those antics
of ancient history infiltrate the
opportunities that we have today we know
that we can lead by example and show
that a well-designed system can produce
results regardless of where the national
rhetoric might be constituent service is
more important than going viral on
Twitter it's been a it's been great to
already see this legislature's eagerness
and willingness to put partisanship
aside and work together
now this year let's commit to find
compromise where we can disagree
amicably where we where we must and
always remember
state are just counting on us to deliver
the voters of New Hampshire do not
reward those who yell the loudest but
they reward those who work hard they
roll up their sleeves and they get the
job done
with such a narrowly divided legislature
we have an incredible opportunity to set
an example for the rest of the nation
so why exactly is it that we are so good
at what we do
well the main reason is is that it
starts with a robust Civics dialogue
it's New Hampshire and every Granite
seder knows somebody who has served in
elective office whether it be a family
member a friend a neighbor maybe it's
the planning board or the school board
Governor whatever it might be we take
pride in our accessibility and our
connectedness to our constituents when
you run into your Selectmen at Dunkin
Donuts or Market Basket you let them
know what's on your mind
Lord knows I have done some of my most
important listening in the serial aisle
of Market Basket in Epping
it's usually because the serial aisle is
so big and I'm staring aimlessly at the
thing trying to figure out what what my
kids want to eat but it is a great
opportunity and we all as public
servants as elected officials have to
find those moments those opportunities
to be great listeners because that's the
expectation
and it's because of our robust Civics
that we continue to lead the way in
engagement and personal responsibility
and individual liberty now I mentioned I
mentioned Mrs lankau's Civics and
government class who's joining us today
so our job is really to deliver results
we know that but just as important we
must set an example for those students
that are sitting up in that Gallery we
must Inspire them keep them involved
instill the principles that make New
Hampshire New Hampshire putting
individuals ahead of big systems
the average citizen is interested in
seeing progress on their genuine issue
so this connection between elected
officials and citizens that's really the
key to success that you really don't
find in most any other state in the
country our entire system is based on
the idea of interconnectedness and
interdependency
and as an engineer I can tell you I
think it's the ideal way to design a
self-regulating system it's Unique in
government it works and we should be
very proud of that but make no mistake
while we stand on the shoulders of 200
years of a disciplined process we're
always just one generation away of
becoming like everybody else and
nationally you've heard a lot of talk
over the past couple years this was an
interesting story The the two words that
we heard a lot on the news parents
matter right
so while those two simple words seem to
be almost like a New Concept in a place
like Virginia they've been a central
concept to our communities in our
government here in New Hampshire since
the very beginning it's not big
government's job to impose its will upon
cities and towns dictating this and
mandating that and saying You must or
you cannot big government
authoritarianism might be the way they
do it in 49 other states but it is not
how we do it here in New Hampshire it's
a very
[Applause]
it's a very simple formula in New
Hampshire we distilled decision making
down to the lowest possible levels of
power empowering individuals to make
their voices heard at the local level
where their voice is the greatest
here in New Hampshire we call it local
control we've been doing it for hundreds
of years but we're not about to stop now
in New Hampshire is not up to
politicians in Concord to dictate how a
one-room schoolhouse a hundred miles
away does things or manages themselves
day to day the power lies with the
parents and with the teachers and with
the Partnerships at that local level
who send their kids to school and manage
those those School rooms day to day our
job is to set up
provide guidelines and more often than
not
frankly get out of the way
you do you Live Free or Die it's more
than just four words on a license plate
it's our way of life here in New
Hampshire and we must remain committed
to upholding those values
[Applause]
too often across this country you have
politicians at every level of power that
think that they know better than the
individual
they get their priorities messed up they
lose sight of why they were elected they
easily forget about the basic tenets of
individual responsibility limited
government fiscal responsibility and
make no mistake when it comes to
government there is no greater
responsibility than managing other
people's money it's not our money it's
their money families across the state
have sweat out their paychecks they work
hard to earn a living and it's our job
to make sure that we're being efficient
and responsible with that trust
but unfortunately too many politicians
don't consider those fiscal issues they
don't consider the importance of
balancing budgets
from their positions of power at State
houses all across this country to the
halls of Congress and Washington too
many of them think they know better than
those that voted them into office and as
a result you have big government
politicians losing sight of why we were
elected what public service is all about
and who exactly we need to be held
accountable to
it's not right to tell a private
business what they can or cannot do it
is not the New Hampshire way to force
locally elected and accountable school
districts or town councils to bend to
the state House's will that's not
leadership it's not conservative and it
is certainly not freedom
thank you
[Applause]
I call it I call it taking the easy way
out but leadership is about knowing the
limitations of your own power getting
government out of the way empowering
those individuals and families to make
the best decisions for themselves this
is America we are a free country and we
believe in the Constitution and the
Constitution gives every American
gives every American the right to make
stupid decisions sometimes right
I guess that's the beauty of being in
such a free country and just because I
may not like something or agree with
what you might have said doesn't mean it
needs to be fixed I sure as heck don't
like what every business might do I I
might not like whatever May whatever
mayor does or whatever school or School
District does
but they're accountable to their own
voters they're accountable to their
local constituents and at last I checked
people don't need politicians or
corporate boardrooms telling them what
is right and what is wrong New Hampshire
will not be lectured or beholden to
out-of-touch politicians who are
disconnected from realities on the
ground that those those issues that are
really facing those businesses and
families today will not be lectured by
out-of-state businesses forcing their
Politics on consumers will not be
lectured by the power Brokers in
Washington D.C this is New Hampshire and
when we do it our way we do it better
than anyone
then
[Applause]
the New Hampshire model works it's
proven and it's why other states are
taking notes this job is much bigger so
much bigger than any of ourselves and we
have to remind ourselves of that every
single day
it's time we take that ego frankly a
little bit of the hypocrisy out of
politics it's time we get out of those
Echo Chambers it's nice to be in that
Echo chamber sometime people tell you
exactly what you want to hear but it's
not real
we have to get back into that real world
we have to hear how our decisions are
affecting people every single day I know
I'm up for the challenge I know this
legislature is up for the challenge and
I know the people of New Hampshire are
going to hold us to it
thank you God bless you and God bless
this great state
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
The Joint convention will please remain
standing while the remervently attentive
to Pastor Michael Woolsey of Manchester
office of benediction
I don't know if this is appropriate or
not but I was so impressed with the
young lady the kid governor who came up
and so confidently and led all of us
grown folks in the Pledge of Allegiance
and then a young lady who sang the
national anthem had a voice of an angel
I really blessed God for the both of you
[Applause]
Governor thank you for this opportunity
elected officials thank you as we close
and prayers you buy your heads father we
thank you so very much
father for this day it's a day that you
have made and Lord we will rejoice and
be glad in it father once again I lift
up our leaders today as they go forth
father and make the decisions and and
helping this continue to be a great
state
father I pray that as we leave this
place
but never from your presence I ask that
the words of our mouths and the
meditations of our heart will be
acceptable in your sight O Lord I'll
rock and Our Redeemer amen
foreign
[Applause]
Commissioners and guests please
foreign
representative Osborne and Senator
Carson move that the joint consumption
rise are you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye
I suppose nay the eyes have it and the
joint convention is adjourned
something
thank you
the house we're still in session the
house house members please stay in your
seats we still have one more motion
house members stay in your sheets
or find a seat
any seat
a house will come to water
the chair recognizes the member from
Auburn representative Osborne for a
motion to adjourn from the early session
a resolved that the house now adjourned
from the early session that the business
of the late session be in order at the
present time and when the house adjourns
today it be to meet at the call of the
chair
are you ready for the question all those
of you ever say aye
those opposed nay you guys have it and
the motion is adopted
representative Osmond moves at the house
stand in recess for the purpose of
introduction of bills vacate motions and
receiving messages are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it and
the motion is adopted the house is in
recess the call of the chair